les employés de l'aéroport roissy
charles de gaulle et d'orly ont mené une
grève pour dénoncer les plans d'économie
la réduction des acquis sociaux ou
encore el abbès d'emploi aujourd'hui est
une démonstration de force ont repris en
martelé les représentants syndicaux
selon eux il était un peu plus de 1000 à
se rassembler ici le but était de
négocier avec la direction le siège d'à
d'été se trouve juste derrière moi
malheureusement les représentants et
syndicaux n'ont pas été accueillis par
la direction
nous avons pu parler à plusieurs
employés qui nous expliquait qu'en
raison de l'épidémie la précarité avait
fait augmenter les conditions de travail
étaient de plus en plus être difficile
je vous propose de les écouter on
demande un engagement l'état dans
l'épreuve qui aujourd'hui concerne le
monde aéronautique
dans son engagement en restant
majoritaire dans le capital de bp en
soutenant
ce qu'on appelle l'aéroport de demain
puisqu'on a des enjeux environnementaux
le plus important c'est que tout le
monde soit mobilisé pour défendre en
fait notre avenir
parce que certains n'ont plus d'emploi
où on est à l'arrêt depuis mi mars
donc je pense qu'il y en a qui sont chez
eux mais ils devraient les faire
reprendre un petit peu parce que il
devrait quand même se soucier s'ils
arrivent à vivre à manger on a déjà
réussi à faire bouger les lignes sur
certains sujets on va continuer et puis
ben c'est le rapport de force qui
s'installe avec aujourd'hui on le voit
les salariés je pense qu'on va être
nombreux et savent aussi faire ça va
permettre à la direction de voir aussi
que les salariés sont pas contents un
appel lancé par la cgt plusieurs corps
de métiers étaient à présent dans ce
cortège on ne lâchera rien c'est ce que
martelait continuellement est les
employés qui étaient présents dans ce
cortège en tout cas plusieurs
mobilisations et rassemblements sont à
venir les négociations elles sont
toujours en cours